[Music]
welcome to air biscuits
I'm Rhett and I'm Linc it's time for
another conversation with someone
interesting from the internet like we do
every single week people at the
roundtable of dim lighting this week it
is anthony padilla and ian hecox the
comedy duo better known as smosh I've
heard of them I've heard of them two
times I've actually met them well well
I'm you were friends but uh you know
they're very busy guys so after we were
both guest on an upcoming epic rap
battle of history mm you know we both
shot all day and then we got here at the
round table of dim light and have a
conversation now you probably know that
Smosh is the second most subscribed
personality fronted channel on YouTube
over seventeen and a half million
subscribers and three billion views I
might have to break out the word
powerhouse a good house like powerhouse
is like weird bringing that out
sometimes well you know this is in other
situations where probably everyone who's
listening already knows knows who Smosh
is and if you just happen to be one of
the few people who don't know they are
you probably have seen one of their
videos if by accident you've seen one of
their videos I mean that yeah they've
got a view for almost half of the
world's population you know but it
doesn't just their main channel those
three billion views they've added to
that they've got Smosh games a channel
with over four million subscribers
they've got an animation based channel
shut up cartoons over a million and a
half subscribers and I'm not making this
up link they have a Spanish dubbed
channel never never watched it I can't
say el Smosh el Smosh with over a
million subscribers and they have their
own magazine they've got a magazine like
a magazine you can go into a magazine
store like a physical magazine Smosh
magazine why I yeah I was in Walgreens
and I've proved it
you perused it I didn't purchase it I'm
gonna be honest I mean I don't purchase
magazines I just look at them they're
what my wife is like getting other stuff
and I'm over here like a tween looking
at a Smosh look at that look at that 35
year old guy
into Smosh magazine Forbes called them a
new purely digital breed of celebrity
and they've been ranked in the Hollywood
30 under 30
two years in a row by Forbes magazine
okay so they've been putting out weekly
sketch based comedy for many years of
their three billion views 100 million of
those views comes from their most
popular video called beef and go hi I'm
Anthony Padilla are you the kind of
person that just loves me but it's
always on the go well I know I am for
years I've searched for an easy way to
eat steak and other meat products with
my on-the-go lifestyle but products like
quickie steak were too inconvenient
while other products like meatball
necklace were just plain messy that is
until I found beef and go they're also
known for their video game-themed music
videos like their Legend of Zelda wrap
which is approaching 50 million
[Music]
Katy Perry
[Music]
okay so being a comedy duo ourselves in
talking to the most successful comedy
duo in the history of the Internet and I
don't think that's any exaggeration
though I was really interested in
talking to them about their friendship
off-camera
you know in the ways that we relate to
each other there's conflict there's
there's lots of coordination when
there's two of us you got to be on the
same page that's not always going to
happen I was curious how they dealt with
that I think at a certain point this ear
biscuit approached a counseling session
yeah it does get into counseling at one
point I don't know who was being
counseled I think it if I think it was
putting it went both ways but yeah you
know we've got this what we feel like is
some insight into what it's like to be a
comedy duo so we ask a lot of questions
have a lot of conversation just about
what that dynamic is and concluding what
is it like to you know have a this big
brand that is this thing that people
understand as Smosh that's also a real
friendship how does that relate to their
lives as individuals the fact that they
live in different cities we talk about a
lot of stuff related to that this is a
this is a duo interviewing a duo and
they have relationships they that they
have on the internet with their
girlfriends differently they approach
degrees to different degrees yeah to
also to different girls yeah that's good
we've always maintained that I always
have a relationship with the different
girl each person in the duo right I mean
we get into a lot of things here so see
if you can learn something new about
Smosh like I said we're glad to call
them friends also collaborators they
were guests on one of the very first
episodes of our half-hour show the
mythical show of last year 2013 so and
we're happy to have them on air biscuit
here's our air biscuit with mosh mosh
homage
[Music]
your water there yeah and this is a new
water and do you feel the need to be
more hydrated well I came in with this
water I didn't know you guys were gonna
be supplying personally whenever there's
more than one water ball in front of me
I'm like I better drink like that one so
I only have one maybe I'll double fist
it yeah well no serve it link is
obsessed with being hydrated
no seriously thanks is your wonderful
skin really yeah is it the hydration or
the urination I think my constant
urination is what will explains my
obsession with hydration hydration leads
to urination but you know that if you
are properly hydrated like if you flood
your body with water
you'll die no you will you can die from
a water overdose have you done that he's
died before yeah yeah it wasn't fun but
water intake your body adjust yeah
somebody did that's real like actually
there's a radio contest in our city
Sacramento somebody somebody died it was
a whole new we for a we that was my aunt
I bet they don't still do like looking
at you're trying to read your face like
is he serious I hate to make light of
water deaths that happened in Sacramento
because I've heard about it yeah all the
radio deejays got fired yep and they
don't do the contest you know I don't
think it was that before or after we
went on that radio show was there a pawn
in there different what a different
Channel you said we went on the show we
would like to play that was the only
other time that we really went on a
radio show and have mics up to our faces
so this is our first podcast Wow
this we are honored breaking the seal
taking that podcast virginity and let me
tell you a sexy
you should have never given us
headphones to hear what we sound like
because with some ways I mean I can turn
it off here no I sit around and just
talk to I could do this
when links not here sometimes it is come
in here to just talk to myself because I
sound so much cooler you do you do after
myself in person you just you're just
like is your philosophy to pee before
you do something important because I
wait or to hold it because I always find
I really have to be realized I just
realized we hosted the video game awards
at South by Southwest and I realized
that I am a nervous like yeah I like
right before I go on I suddenly have to
go yeah and I trace that back to like
every time we've done a live thing at
VidCon that I've I thought maybe I just
ate something bad but like literally
every every time I do like a live thing
I get way nervous okay similarly I like
psych myself out I'm like do I have to
pee I better go pee right now and then
for some reason I always convince myself
that I'm cold and then I need to really
make sure my hands are warm I think
that's some internet pee on them okay I
don't know I think it's some kind of a
mental disorder well but no it's natural
to evacuate before you do something
important I mean that's just a
biological system it's like flying just
lessen the weight kind of it goes back
to it goes back to your ancestors that
needed to run after animals on the
plains for long periods of time it was
like listen I'm gonna be chasing this
gazelle for the next two days I better
take a bill do spray yeah so I could I'm
serious man I always I was trying to
evacuate as much as possible before I
did like a running sort of race the
worst for me was my first day of school
every year I don't know why what oh man
yeah I always felt like I was so nervous
I don't know why at the school before I
think this you're highly need to
differences between me right I'm kind of
curious where you guys fall on this one
is right now I always get in an argument
about this whole pee thing because we're
about like if we do something live on a
stage I'm like I'll be right back yeah
again
and he's like no hold it harness no
harness that use that use that vision
the performance because then the whole
time all you're thinking about is how
you have to pee no but then if he has to
pee the whole time all I'm thinking
about is how he has to be it and then it
can be contagious but the second thing
you mentioned being really nervous
before your first day at school and
having to evacuate I have always been
that way too I pristinely remember every
school year just being a nervous wreck
before the first day of school
whereas Rhett right I I mean correct me
if I'm wrong I know we've talked about
it that the first day of school is
always like your best day ever like you
cannot wait to get there really so
excited you get like the new the new
school clothes and everything but there
was no anxiety so you're saying you like
that was always a nervous thing for you
the worst day of my life every every
year was that first day is kind of an
irrational it's just this yeah a new
beginning the unknown it's weird cuz I
like wasn't even really scared I just
was like okay crap
literally like right I was never nervous
about my classes I was just like when
when you first go into the class and
everybody chooses what what seat they
want to sit in
nobody ever like chose a seat next to me
meet so I was always Stokes whenever
they had those presets like this but
that's also carried over which now I'm
like grateful for it nobody wants to sit
next me on a plane so like you think you
just give off that vibe I guess so and I
guess I gave that vibe off in school to
do so now it's actually paid off so like
I don't know if I'm just like really
boss it's electing like airplane seats
but literally like the entire plane will
fill up and I will be the one with the
last remaining empty seat next to me
what's the look on your face I don't
give anybody a look I just I'm just
doing my thing how do you do look
forward like a serial killer doing
something you just don't know do it I
mean sometimes I'm I'm you know stabbing
a doll that looks like just your average
airline passenger yeah
I'm just I'm just a vac you know I get
nervous I just
okay yeah yeah the evacuation that
probably creates a radius that guys
grabbed his pants and he's stabbing a
duck I'm not sitting next to him I bet
his girlfriend is gonna be here any
second now how many people are gonna
start trying there now well it's not
worth it it's a crappy pain you might
have a little bit of extra leg room an
arm room but you've just crapped your
pants so so but you're not the type are
you also the type to get anxious like
before some sort of live gig I mean the
whole usually I just weren't so much
control yeah that then when you have to
go into this live format first time I
saw you guys live was at YouTube live
you know you had that you guys had to
introduce something oh man I was stage I
was only like a three second spot and I
was so nervous yeah yeah yeah I was a
different world cuz it's live and you
can't you can't edit it before it goes
up yeah I'm really terrible with like
just being on in the spotlight I don't
really like it yeah so like you know
even like in class like when when you
had to go around and say who you were
like some classes like you say who you
were and like what you like to do like
my heart would be beating like ten
people away like they go down the line
there's like I'm like ten people away
I'm like oh you're like practicing your
name under your breath like the fact
that everyone is so nervous they're not
even listening to what anyone else is
saying so you're nervous for no reason
like no there are a few people who
aren't nervous like I'm saying about
Rhett that's it that's like he likes
know what's his problem
that's weird well I I don't sit I was
nervous and I do get nervous when we do
when we do live stuff definitely but I
wasn't thinking about I was thinking
about I got to say the right thing so
they'll think the right thing about me
the rest of the year that's what I was
thinking is like this this is the chance
right now you got to say I can't say I
like snow because for the record who
doesn't like snow yeah come on if you
live in Sacramento I mean it's yeah you
like snow what you don't like a novelty
yeah yeah okay okay so we're talking
about class I think this this is a good
a segue is ending into how you guys met
so I assume that there's kind of this
normal story you tell yeah have you read
the story because it seems like you kind
of are on the right track but you can
give us I knew that it's kind of a
middle school that you guys matter it's
great okay so that that's the first year
middle school in my mind for some people
oh maybe there's no our common now but
where we grew up it was sixth grade was
elementary you were the big kids in the
elementary school so that's what I
assumed yeah I have I've read the Smosh
lore so I guess this is the forum for
you to to say what you actually remember
not what's been written in a Wikipedia
well we remember now is what's been
written like slowly change them like so
I was raised as a girl yeah I love snow
probably no right because that's if
that's what your wiki says yeah that's
what you believe but you do I I guess
you do find yourself telling this part
of the story so I don't know I don't
want you telling in a fresh way okay
what's a fresh way the high-pitch boys
maybe Japanese acknowledging this may be
the the thing that you that you have to
say a lot and then people okay we got it
yeah we'll quote how many views you get
it and subscribers you have and then
that'll be the thing yeah
but take us back there what what year is
this sixth grade it was a nice sunny day
1998 I'm guessing something like that I
just moved to that town so the big ass
loser could use the new cut
kid and moving from where from basically
just a different side of the town
because my parents didn't want me to
it's actually where the Smosh house is
yeah yeah I grew up in an area that was
it was it was okay but the high school
you they had like gang problems and
stuff so so my parents didn't want me
going there and you know becoming a [ __ ]
or a blood they didn't have a snow
liking gang that you could be a part of
but I never checked yeah but so yeah we
moved we moved on to the other side of
the city where they had this decent high
school for me my sister to go see so I
went there sixth grade met Anthony well
actually the first time we met was in
this class so yeah was it that did we
merge like classes because there was our
science class did were we in the same
class and then we I don't know it was
weird way to go to a different a
different room I just realized that our
teacher kind of looked like Seth
MacFarlane yeah he's a creeper he was a
creep but it was a guy yeah yeah he's a
guy yeah but well we got we went to this
different room to be with a different
teacher to learn science was kind of
weird yeah but it was this woman teacher
I don't remember her name I can't say
I'm saying that I'll believe anything
every night and was it the type of was
it okay we are lab partners and now
we're best friends type thing or there's
just an acquaintance like okay I met you
and along with everybody else yeah we
were paired up and it was the first time
I ever really talked something she's
just the new kid yep and we're paired up
and they're like all right you're gonna
be drawing gonna be drawing a dump a
landfill really I don't know why that's
where we met going to landfills all
about landfills and stuff yeah so and
fills some reason we thought it was the
funniest thing ever to draw gas masks
and flies and points flying all kind of
cutting goes back to our the
conversation we all had rights being any
of this right it's interesting that we
met course it was first grade our
Wikipedia dictates to us no I'm just
trying to connect okay I get it you guys
are better
I see no no I'm not saying that they can
do and it was well before 1999
or whatever that was but when we met we
were held in from recess and being being
punished and we had to color pictures we
so we were both drawing pictures was not
the same unethical be saying sir you
were both in trouble yeah but in ways of
landfill yeah you guys look like some
serious were the only to the only 2d
helping kids in trouble yeah that day
yeah did you guys beat each other up no
we were like or did you just beat kids
up so bad that they like didn't why'd
you get in trouble for profanity on the
dash desks you guys prevented yeah yeah
yeah right in front of us we have a desk
that we can draw on right yeah but you
can't write profane at all in this are
we gonna get in trouble or we're gonna
have to draw mythical creatures I will
put you in detention
enjoy the same picture like is it like
yeah it was one paper and we do yeah I
mean I had that land think about that
yeah
what could you ebay that for I think he
was joking with separate landfills 10
but no we really were drawn it was the
same landfill is the same paper yeah
yeah with the same tag team drawings
pretty sweet viral it was a spy I didn't
I basically the way we did it was I held
Anthony's hand yeah we drew it together
like a Ouija board so do you remember
thinking boy I like the way that guy
draws a gas mask I respect him
creatively the one that drew the gas
mask you're trying to flies I don't know
but we we laughed till we cried it seems
like something that's not funny at all
and it's not but for some reason it's
sixth-graders it was the funny maybe we
drew really hilarious gas masks and
flies well I still remember it for some
reason I can't what do you remember
though it was this a beginning of a
friendship you know it's like it's like
you know when you uh when you go to
prison you know oh oh we all know about
you guys are the troublemakers there's
no survival thing you know so you gotta
you gotta get in there and
and you know gonna take your claim and
you know try to find I was your claim
yeah I guess her claim I guess I was you
were his affiliation school affiliation
hey see I have a friend now I joined the
bug like basically a gang I even know it
I was your [ __ ] hey that's pretty much
what was that yeah yeah so then yeah it
was just like a group of a group of
friends that and then I took you we
initiated you into our group of yeah and
so for loser friends like one of them
like hated me up until like up until
like Ryan Ryan hated you said you didn't
like me until a couple years later I
don't think Ryan fights either of us I
don't know but uh but yeah so we just we
just stayed friends until you know just
hung out played Goldeneye played perfect
dark
yeah played halo I mean we're working
through the videogame years that's a
good that's why define like the the
years in our Friday the video game yeah
yeah yeah we were pretty good friends
but never like super close until high
school and I got my driver's license and
a car before
Ian and he needed a ride home and it
just so happened he's kind of on the way
home so he bummed rides off me carpool
huh yeah it was totally for carpool
reasons right Ian now he bombed rides
his amazing 429 Ford Probe so okay so
you're in a group of friends yeah and
did it quickly become like okay yeah
we're in this group of friends but you
know the two of us we're besties we're
best friends or were just two guys in a
group of friends like how is that
shaping up there is I mean I started we
were just two guys in a group of friends
yeah there's definitely times that that
it seemed like we weren't included on
some cool kid things
mm-hmm we were we were kind of losers in
high school yeah so so sometimes our
friends would do some stuff with people
that were kind of too cool for us yeah I
don't know if we necessarily weren't
invited but we were like alright let's
maybe I wasn't listening when they
invited me
yeah who knows but yeah so I mean
Anthony started the website Smosh comm
sophomore year of high school so that
was all of our friends all of our
friends were kind of participating in
the for a month back in 2002 yeah that's
all the Smosh comm was was for your I
made a girlfriend girlfriends yeah yep
to discuss what probably girls girls I
don't know I really don't know honestly
we were just like oh what are we doing
this weekend we're doing this oh man
it'd be funny if we there's no random
stuff what games are you guys playing
yeah it was weird
and then uh my smosh smosh well that was
something that another story we tell a
lot that was something that our friend
Ryan the one that told me that he was
like he's like I hated you for like when
I first Ryan would always very nice guy
very honest so basically he he went to a
blink 182 concert back when that was a
thing and he he was bragging about how
he was in a mosh pit right yeah he said
Smosh pit yep yes Ryan was talking to me
he's like I was in the Smosh pit it was
freaking it was insane I was like you
should say small I said mosh pit I'm
like now I'm pretty sure he said Smosh
pit so we walked it was he and I walking
over to a group of friends I was like
Brian said Smosh pit ba Baba I don't
know why we thought that was funny what
we did I just kind of became with an
inside joke for all your friends and it
became the name of the forum yeah yeah
well yeah and then oh is this super nerd
that basically built websites all the
time so then I was like man I don't have
any websites to work on I want to work
on something else's in this web design
class I was like oh man I should make
this site cold what am I gonna call it
call it Smosh it's where me and my
friends mm-hmm
that was a good idea you can't get a
five letter word URL anymore like and
how did so how did that progress to you
guys make it videos well first it
started out we we were into like before
YouTube there is this place called
Newgrounds and it was
they hosted flash animation okay that's
not still around actually yeah yeah it's
not as popular I have some really
terrible animations on yeah yeah we so
we were both like really interested in
like flash flash a flash I think you
would say the word flash but yeah so
like we were we were just into that kind
of stuff and so he started hosting flash
animations on on our website on his
website yeah and you helped pay $2 a
month on that I did I refused all the
friends pitched in two dollars a month
early investors yeah exactly
and so after high school gimmick was I
got to keep all the ad revenue of the
$20 a month and so when we graduated
from high school all of our friends were
going off to college and Anthony and I
were going to commute we're gonna go to
Community College just in in our city
and we're just like bored one day
decided to how we were listening to like
the Power Rangers theme so I'm like
that'd be really funny if we made some
stupid video of us lip-synching it and
okay yeah that was before YouTube that's
before we even heard of it so we hosted
it on on Smosh calm on our own with our
own bandwidth yeah so so then we
displayed it on our MySpace page when
there was a thing and I thought this
genius idea I was like well okay I'll
put the video playing on my page and
then I'll put a box below it that lets
you copy paste the video is put on your
page but the thing is whatever you copy
paste of that and put on your page
there'd be another box that would say
copy paste this and that was like a
early form of viral sharing so it was
you it was coding that you developed
that showed like the HTML you want yeah
so then we made a Mortal Kombat Theme
song lip sync thing and well so the
power ranger one did well some people
watched it our friends liked it yeah our
friends on MySpace
friends and then like because we had the
flash animation on our website there was
there's a few people on the website that
sod as well that's right
got it got to a few other people that
weren't just art yeah cool so you
followed it up with Mortal Kombat and
somebody stole that video put it on
youtube before we knew what YouTube was
and somebody somebody's like hey your
did somebody tell us what did you know
so I was I was bored searching on Google
it's like oh man would that be so cool
if like someone I'd like talking about
our video or something you know so I did
a Google search and I found it on this
site YouTube and I had like the name was
I had like 100 users or a thousand views
or something like that was which is
which was like really huge back then
yeah yeah yeah yeah we could remember
what the website name was cuz we were
like oh man was that site we should go
back to it and we couldn't remember a
few days later we I thought it was you I
thought it was I - I can't find that I -
but I will will interject at this point
because people may be making this
connection out there listeners of are so
interesting obviously the one parallels
were both duo's who met when we were
younger bonded over drawing and then got
into YouTube because someone else took
and this must be the way all YouTube
duo's come together though you know we
start asking around us oh yeah same
thing happened video got stolen put on
YouTube and then got all these views and
that was when you're like oh yeah we
should be doing this all that purpose I
was called pimp my stroller include your
kids in your video parody in an MTV
television show with a stroller yeah on
our website we had a way to
rhettandlink.com/store him it was just
hey let's put videos of some of the
videos that we like the same exact yeah
but were they spreading around or was it
just so we'll see your friends I watched
it or what yeah weird they were
definitely not spreading around but that
one got a lot of views just like what
you're saying say oh I've got a thousand
views on its Mortal Kombat thing yeah so
then you decided now let's do Pokemon
yeah so what that was
next one well we there was I mean we
uploaded we asked the guy to remove the
video and we uploaded our Power Rangers
and Mortal Kombat videos to YouTube and
and at that time you could ask you could
ask people to like people could
basically suggest videos to be be put on
the homepage there was a button on the
bottom of every video yes I said suggest
for home page so we asked the the small
following that we had to hit that button
for us
well the fall it was more like on our
aim instant messaging profiles as my
away message yeah yeah so we I hosted a
poll on myspace I said which what would
you guys like to see us make next and
then Pokemon won by landslide there was
like really stupid there was like
Captain Planet and and Inspector Gadget
the hymn songs but Pokemon blew
everything away and you were just
lip-syncing these yeah I mean we spice
it up a little bit because it wasn't it
was it was a little bit more than what
people were doing at the time a lot of
people were doing lip-sync things right
yes we the Chinese Backstreet Boys do
you remember those that's way back yeah
yes I do remember that they were wearing
the basketball jerseys yeah yeah right
you're like we got to do a little bit of
competition they were the benchmark for
us right they were huge and we were like
so so what was the second turning point
I mean if the Pokemon thing was like oh
there's we have an audience hmm second
turning point is definitely when YouTube
said hey we could pay you some money to
do this and how much how far down the
road is that was that a year later or
just months later it was a year and a
half later I think it was beginning 2000
so a year and a half it was just you
continue the same pattern yeah gained
popularity but it was still just like
goofing off hobby and you were still in
school yeah yeah I mean just something
that we thought we partnered with his
little tiny website that paid us a
little bit so we had enough money to pay
for props and stuff like that so we
weren't losing money making the videos
but we definitely weren't making
anything but yeah that that turning
point is what YouTube
contacted you directly that's how they
did with the first yeah it was like to
your partner so it was like lisanova us
what the Brian what the buck Ryan Higa
probably I don't remember yeah and
they're like hey we'll give you a cut of
the ad revenue yeah so how did you know
I'm thinking about the way that that we
worked once we started thinking about
having this and this is kind of the way
that we always were as we would have
these like strategy meetings right
regardless of what it was that we were
trying to do together or trying to
accomplish we kind of come together be
like all right we we got to figure this
out it seems like there was a point at
which you guys had this goal that you
kind of came together and said let's
let's accomplish something together I
mean do you remember what that process
was like because you know going from
being friends to guys that are just
hanging out trying things for fun to two
guys who are like oh no we're this is
like a thing we are a thing trying to
accomplish something yeah we're probably
brand you're Smosh it's a thing yeah
it's uh we were just two guys just
making videos whenever we felt like it
once every two to four weeks just kind
of hanging out not planning any growth
or it's like let's just keep doing the
same thing for the rest of our lives and
then we met up with Barry who's the
president of our company now and he's
like you guys you guys should think on a
big scale like make more make more
videos and and how did you meet him and
where do you come from
it's funny he emailed us yeah he emailed
us he was the president of ice ex vice
president of Disney Animation yeah
Disney television ma tellers manager
yeah yeah so the funny story sorry yeah
he was like he was like hey I really
like you guys I really like you know he
said ham you know ex blah blah blah
Disney blah blah I really like your
guy's voice and I think we should meet
up and have a discussion and then I was
like he likes our voice he wants to do
voices for animation
[Laughter]
I didn't realize that he meant he liked
comedic tone our comedic tone yes we
learned very soon F yeah like in the
meeting you came with like seven
different boys practice my you know his
blames me though for he's like he's like
Anthony thought it meant that yeah I'm
like you were there with me maybe he's
right just like a voice I just stay
quiet but why did he say voice
singularly trying to figure that one out
but I mean it's if I were in your shoes
having that meeting with Barry I would
be very I mean I guess we had meetings
like that where it was someone saying
okay I want to team up with you guys I
want to partner with you guys to make
you a bigger success we be very
skeptical and have a lot of trust issues
with that we definitely were you know
it's it's the type of thing I mean
someone's got the right credentials
obviously III think we can look at your
work and I think infer that once you
involved
maybe it's Barry maybe there's even more
people from there that there was a there
was a there was a turn a corner that
Smosh turn it was like okay all of a
sudden it's not just limited by two guys
but there's a lot going on there's
multiple channels there's all these
things but at that moment it must have
been a huge decision was all of a sudden
you're not just two guys making funny
videos but you're you have to be
business men and you just can't you know
it's not like you can just turn around
to your parents and say hey what do you
think I should do right especially the
time no one had ever done anything like
that right yeah you have no one that
could be a mother because he worked for
free for us for a long time and kind of
I don't know if it was on purpose but he
really proved himself and we just earned
your trust exactly yeah and I mean he he
got us thinking on a on a on a level
that we weren't thinking of at that
point because you know we're just we're
just two dudes and all we cared about
was just
making a dumb video every once in a
while and you know didn't really think
about long term and that kind of stuff
so he got us thinking bigger like you
know growing out the website you know
producing more content convinced us to
get a camera guy yeah convinced us yeah
that was another thing it's like it's
like when you why are you trying to do
everything when you should try to focus
on the creative creative and and have
you know people do basically all the
things that we could teach someone we
should teach someone and all the things
that are like super you know whatever
creative or whatever that only we could
do is the only thing that we should be
focusing on so what what specifically
did you decide to focus on and then
leave everything else to somebody else
that you're gonna entrust through Barry
what were those things that you that you
decided to hold on to writing and acting
and we did something we did a lot of the
directing we did almost all that all the
back then we handed off things like but
not editing actually yeah I did all the
editing you kept editing yeah oh yeah
yeah that sounds lighted with this I
mean it was like years yeah yeah very
slow things like very slow getting
getting props and you know making the
props and you know casting camera yeah a
producer like the cast people get all
the props and then what about fast
forward to now how does it work now I
think I'm I think we're fascinated we
have a very well oiled machine going on
not not I mean you guys live in
different towns I'm fascinated from a
from a professional standpoint what do
you guys focus on and then what do you
entrust to other people how do you how
do you guys kind of divide up the labor
what are your strengths well now it's
like tween the two much better process
yeah cuz before like Anthony was was
doing the brunt of the editing and ian
was doing the brunt of all the right
yeah so we've so luckily like we've
we've taken the the editing I mean we
still like you should see the notes that
especially like Anthony gives like
because we have we have an editor and we
send him a bunch of notes like I give a
novel of notes but he's been editing for
us for three years now so he's kind of
almost learned how our brain works and
he'll like just go there now but now
it's like Anthony and I can really focus
on like writing the writer brainstorms
it's just a lot better process now every
week we're on probably 10 12 hours of
writing and brainstorm calls just just
with each other to make it flesh out the
next video yeah yeah so there's a your
release schedule is one major video or
AZ release schedule if you really break
it down because we we have the one major
release a week then we have the bloopers
and behind the scenes which we also
still have a big part in getting all the
notes on that and stuff too that's just
for main channel and then they were
second channel which is weird only in
one video week on there now which is
either our lunch vlogs or just a random
type thing that we do together which is
still called ian is bored been both of
us on there for the past three years
it's like like three years ago we're
like well maybe you're like maybe I
should be in these videos - yeah okay
and then another thing we should call
smosh's board it's like okay it's all
year's board but yeah if you trace it
back like you'll find like maybe three
years ago and you were actually bored I
was actually probably bored for the
first three maybe and then yeah but on
the on the subject of like yeah work
videos we make like it's it's the second
channel then also two videos on our
gaming shamash games yeah we oversee a
lot of a lot of those videos give them
notes on those five videos a week
basically and yeah but you live you used
to live in Sacramento correct and you
live here I live down here yet so it's
it's crazy because every two weeks I fly
up and we shoot in Sacramento we shoot a
batch of our sketch videos and then we
have
some of the vlogs that we sometimes
shoot every once in a while when
everybody come up there for that every
other week yes and then yeah and then
Ian flies down here every two to four
weeks and we shared a bunch of gaming
videos and then you know we appear on
things like this and guest spots on
other youtubers stuff and so how did you
make that decision I mean like how did
you make the decision and then and was
it an easy decision and has it been
difficult Oh for like the mood for the
move yeah um it was pretty is a
difficult decision for sure I really
want to live down here Ian really wants
to live in Sacramento and what like one
day Anthony was like I think I'm gonna
move down to LA it was like I was like
okay we'll make it work yeah like and
then like an hour later I was like what
are we gonna do but we but you know we
figured it out a little over a year ago
and the process has been getting better
and better
yeah we figured it all out but that but
that was the initial conversation was
you saying to Ian yeah I think I'm gonna
move to LA it was like an announcement
yeah I mean I was hanging out of his
house I was we were finishing editing on
yeah yeah I felt like if I'd asked him
he would have just been like no so what
went into that decision
I really like it down here and I don't
know I just feel like I wasn't growing
in Sacramento I don't know it's a really
small town so it wasn't like LA or
something I mean you know I have my
girlfriend her fiancee I was called a
girlfriend I feel like fiance is such a
douchebag e-word know we both agree to
call each other girlfriend boyfriend is
just weird saying fiance I feel like I
got to say with a French accent or
something that was not French thank you
say let's not get on a rabbit trail so
youmu was she living here no she lived
down here when we met and then she moved
up to Sacramento to be with me for a
while and then she really likes it down
here and I mean that helped in the
decision but most
decision was me like I feel like even if
I wasn't with her at the time I would
have wanted to move down here was
interesting it's okay if she's the
reason she's do some extra points yeah
just what there's an interesting dynamic
to this you know with Lincoln died when
we decide like where we're going to like
right now we're still renting but
hopefully buying houses you know at some
point there's a conversation that's just
like well okay well whoever buys the
house first is kind of telling the other
guy where he's going to live in town
dictating where the other guy lives
right because la is a big place and so
yeah right I bought a house in Compton
right also sound a lucrative record deal
with death-row references so I'm you
know that would be very there would be a
very difficult thing as I think about
how we would relate what's the nature of
the conflict do you have is it are there
is their creative conflict is there also
interpersonal conflict like do you have
a fight over the idea about is funny to
fall off the bike you also have an eye
you know I know we don't really ever
fight it's always I mean sometimes it's
like there's usually a reason for one
person to be the correct one
yeah they will get I mean that's why we
need decipher week both layouting from
long period of time we both lay out our
discussion and one person is eventually
like all right I mean yeah either it's
not a battle worth having or I mean we
agree with you we certainly a lot of our
arguments and in whoever's voice raises
the highest yeah he must feel it's not
his idea must be he must have more
reasons it's he must feel more strongly
about this because his voice is louder
than mine I don't think I could be in a
creative partnership with Rhett cuz like
just stature wise you just scare the
hell out of him into saying he's not
falling off the bike that's not funny
okay ready don't what I mean but we do
it like link and I will sometimes get
into an argument that if there's someone
else like somebody some of our staff are
in the room I leave they just kind of
just sit there with this look on their
face like all right okay I'll start
sweating how long is this going to last
know what we do a lot is sometimes a lot
of times when we're writing
we'll have our buddy Ryan on there with
us and he'll writing Fred he'll he'll
help to throw ideas off of yes so we get
an easy he's a middle man basically so
we're like we you know I'll just back
and forth like five minutes he'll be
like you know what Ryan what do you
think
yeah he'll give us his honest opinion so
that was that a lot do you guys get
pissed at each other personally I mean
the retina in a lot of ways we spend so
much time together for so many years
that we even describe our own friendship
more as like an old married couple or
yeah like what I mean we literally we
get we just get mad at each other like
Ray gets mad at me because I'm so
sensitive about things like I get mad at
him because not of what he says but how
he says it to me and he's like why are
we arguing about this you know there's
those type of arguments that have
nothing to do with a video idea they
just have to do with how are we getting
along should we get counsel does that
does that happen with you guys it's a
it's a weird dynamic cuz I think Ian is
very like I said reserved
you know he'll he'll just keep his
feelings in I don't even know what he's
feeling out time he'll just be quiet
yeah I'm like going right now but then
does it do you bottle up and then you
let it out and you like like there's
probably like 20 years of stuff that he
hasn't told me I haven't blown up on I
don't know I kind of tell my feelings
right away yeah and and you just won't
I'll just sit there just kind of nod
gonna be like yeah but you can tell he's
upset oh yeah but but then it just is
like I don't want to keep nagging him to
get it out of him I'll just be like all
right he'll tell me when he's ready nope
never gonna
never never it just goes away it's
definitely been things that ian has
never told me that he was mad about that
he just was like okay quietness and
what's your approach I mean what is it
does it does it dissolve in the depths I
don't I think he I think he secretly
hates me because he's never told me
about these things that if I do that I'm
not gonna tell you so I could just be
harboring these murderous rage feelings
yeah yeah well that's why I'm asking do
I Harbor murderous rage for Anthony sure
I don't think so
it's so it dissolved it's not the type
of thing that I've never been like I'm
just like it's probably like in I get I
get really like easily like butthurt
over like over acting direction because
you do I would never know I never knew
that instance well just cuz Anthony and
I are really specific about like a
certain way lines should be delivered
and stuff and we totally tell it to like
other actors that come hunter set but
then it's like when when when he gives
like me a direction like should do that
better or something yeah maybe so like
that I I get I get definitely get
butthurt over it and then I realize
afterwards like why did I get angry
about that video alternate I just you
know as needed to do that better for a
while I I don't know if I ever told you
but I was like I was a little mad
because I would always give you a lot of
direction and have you do like 20
different takes and you would always be
like yeah I think it's good to my takes
I'm like yeah I want you to get the best
out of me that I could get I'm like I'm
just doing weird stale takes and you
have all these like crazy takes that
high life got out of you our producer
Ryan said that when I die he's going to
put on my tombstone the quote whatever
because that's my that's my common
response to a like what about this shot
I'm like he'll be like you're like do
you think we should shoot like this or
do you think we should shoot
this um whatever like whatever you think
is better man I'm definitely more of the
go with the flow path of least
resistance type guy
Ian's more into the writing and yeah but
you don't know most of the writing at
first it sounds like you guys are like
no option knows it's hard to say cuz I
mean like sometimes you know Anthony
would come come up with an idea
sometimes I come up that idea but there
was there was a time that Anthony was
taking the brunt of the editing sure so
I was taking a brunt of the outlining
and here's an overall funnier person's
were you very opinionated about the
script but then when it came to the
other things you like whatever and then
like yes since I wrote this since I
wrote the outline and then Anthony would
would tell me things he didn't like I
guess I get by her but her over that too
you get hurt easily but you never tell
me that creative it's just a creative
thing you just you take ownership over
something and then when somebody tells
you that it's not good you're like what
do you mean yeah right yeah a problem
for a while as ian would get stuck in
writing us everything a certain type of
way and there was no evolution it was
just all a very safe certain type of way
and I'd be like we need to grow when you
do things different definitely right
well and you know we deal with this all
the time with with coming up with ideas
and presenting ideas to one another and
you know we kind of develop this
philosophy and it's you don't do it we
try to do it but we don't always do it
but like hold your ideas out here and
those who are listening I'm holding it
next to me instead of in front of me so
when somebody hates on your idea they're
not hating you then right right okay so
you can't you kind of learn to live okay
I think the analogy is when somebody
shoots down your idea it doesn't hit you
right with the bullet so it's so you you
just you learned to take criticism but
it's I mean it's tough I I think one of
the dynamics is maybe maybe the fact
that you guys are in different cities
may you know that actually may be
something that I think the reason that
link and I are like okay well we we have
to get our feelings out there and we
have to deal with this like I'm like
everyone
it's like alright we're gonna have a
conversation it's gonna be a two-hour
conversation but it's not about ideas
this is about our relationship with each
other guys so we have to keep they're
around each other's no yeah but this is
a like a 9:00 a.m. to 6:00 p.m. every
single weekday right the plus the
commute you're not counting yeah yeah
people in the other yeah and so and
because we are committed to this thing
being in an indefinite endeavor is oh
it's like marriage counseling oh
definitely
that's amazing no we know we've we've
actually talked about that we're like
what do you think we could been it like
no I'm let me let me let me preface this
by saying that we I think we have a
really we have a really good friendship
because we talk about our friendship
it's like that's it because we kind of
deal with it on that level but we had a
guy come into the office to kind of like
evaluate the team like as a as a almost
like a fun team building exercise but he
also helps you understand the different
dynamic personalities and how who can
work together and where there might be a
conflict and then we never did it but we
were like I wonder what it would be like
for us just just just sit down with this
guy and say alright you know how we're
different you see our personality
profiles like how can we work together
better yeah so I would not say oh where
did we need to go to counseling but you
know I I think it's so idea was to turn
ear biscuits into recorded counseling I
might be happening right now I wanted to
have no healing sessions legitimate
counseling sessions couples therapy for
the two of us and then only if we can
monetize it I mean those counselors are
expensive yeah all right and I realize
that it's been broadcasted to you know
hundred thousand people or whatever so
we take it weighing back do it we didn't
do it but back to counseling you guys
but I think I think like part of the
part of the the way that we kind of fix
that that creative hurdle that we were
that we were in was that now that we're
both collaborating together we're
building those ideas together now
instead of me instead of us talking
about an idea I write something and I
come
Anthony and then he tells me what we
have a much better process because
before we when we weren't collaborating
together we'd get down to like the end
of a script and it would be so far gone
I was like I can't just dare your idea
to shreds yeah but now I won't let Nydia
go unless I'm really happy with it you
know yeah I won't let it get turned into
a video well what about the kind of
division of characters all right
I'm kind of curious how you guys would
describe the on-camera versions of
yourselves I was gonna say each other
but I think it's safer and fairer to
describe yourself I'll let you go first
hmm your on-camera persona because you
write for that yeah right well you kind
of yeah I mean I think we were I think
somehow we were my character is more
fleshed out than Anthony's was like
Anthony were the basically like for a
long time I was kind of like the idiot
and Anthony was more the straight
character that was playing off of the of
my idiot mmm it is he yeah of my idiocy
I guess you say and and like you know
about a year ago Anthony was like hey
like we should probably try to figure
out a way to make me more interesting I
was like every interesting can you make
me more stupid no I look at every
interesting duo in a movie look at a
super bad like those two have a great
dynamic look you could see one would be
on screen hilarious one the other one be
on screen by themselves hilarious but en
and iean was hilarious and then I'm just
like no stop being dumb like always
that's would be my character so so I
guess that goes onto my character was
just the straight guy that kept the
story moving forward but but now I'm
trying to evolve it a little bit cuz I
was always jealous I was like he knows
all the funny lines yeah I mean until we
got to like unless we did like a thing
where we played character right I
playing characters we we tried to divide
try to divide like whenever do like if
movies are real or anything like that we
look at all the all the characters and
we're like okay let's like evenly yeah
right so I would kind of hate playing
mice
because I would just always be the my
here's what I would say why are you
doing that stop that that's my voice in
every single video pretty much saying
the same exact thing
well did you in how did you guys dress
that um who brought it up so Jen's good
lines and me just being that what are
you doing guy I mean Anthony's more of
more he looks ahead to try to figure out
how we can make things better and then
I'm I'm more complacent like I just
whatever exactly whatever so it's it's
kind of it's kind of an interesting an
interesting thing because yeah we
haven't exactly found a remedy for my
character situation because we still
want a Ian's character to be similar to
how it was who's really good and then
mine I'm like how can i how can i evolve
this you know my smartass do I am I
overly confident with everything even
though I'm you know not necessarily the
smartest person yeah that's kind of the
the way we're going I know berry CH
berry tried to explain it he compared it
to some old-ass TV show that we never
heard of he's older old and he said it
was like it was like his character
that's an idiot but thinks he's a
character that's dumb but thinks he's
smart and then the other person is dumb
but thinks the other one is smart mmm
makes sense right well I think it would
be encouraging for anybody who's trying
to do anything creative to know that
guys who have been doing this as long as
you guys have with the success that
you've seen are still trying to figure
out something that could be considered
that fundamental and let me tell you
right now we totally relate to that we
all we have fundamental level of
conversations about our comedy and like
what is it we're trying to do and like
what who are you supposed to be in this
and mmm and after like you know eight
nine years of doing it it's you know
you're trying to figure out what to do
next with it right and sometimes just
what are you trying to do next week with
it yeah there's the added pressure of
doing something every week with really
an expectation of never taking a break
really I mean we you can but that's not
the expectation it's not like
traditional media in terms of seasons
anything are you guys do you experience
more pressure at this point in your
careers being you know at the top after
all these years is it is the pressure
even greater now and what's the biggest
fear
I'd say the pressure is like almost a
snowball effect it's just more and more
and more every year for me at least yeah
I think you know we've we've been
focused for years event has been trying
to get us on a good schedule so like
we're not killing ourselves every single
week like Oh grab what's what's next
week uh you know so I think in that
regards like we're we've we've like
hammered out a really good schedule so
we're not we're not going crazy we we I
mean but maybe it's not last time we
pulled an all-nighter I mean we haven't
pulled an all-nighter in like three we
said well then almost every week yeah I
don't really mean I guess this the
pressure to deliver on a schedule as
much as the pressure to remain
successful and more successful I mean
you know there's it's lonely at the top
it's how the saying goes
and there's how do you stay there I
don't feel the pressure to be successful
for some reason I feel pressure to have
the audience like what we're still doing
have have anyone that's watching it not
be like wow this sucks compared to
whenever you know I want them to always
be like oh you're growing evolving and I
love this so are you you know you're
afraid that you're not gonna be relevant
you're not I mean is that somewhere
there but to me it's always been for
some reason comments and the way that
people react to videos has always been
something that I say really close to
heart I mean we haven't really worried I
mean we just want to just try to grow
our brand and and just create good
content and if you know we're not really
worried about quote-unquote success but
you know we just want to grow the brand
and as long as we keep creating content
that people enjoy then the successful
hosen follow mm-hmm and obviously guys
like you have been approached probably
numerous times by different
media companies who want to want the
Smosh TV show who want the Smosh movie
how are you guys thinking about the
moving forward into the future and all
the things that you have I mean you guys
launched a freaking magazine you know
it's like you're kind of in a position
where you can do what it is you want and
you're the ones who make those decisions
I mean how do you how do you look into
the next decade I mean I think it's just
about picking the right things we have
all these things that we want to try but
then it's always it always falls back to
I we can't stop doing YouTube on the
schedule that we're on yeah I mean it's
it's we just want to keep doing what
we're we're doing right now you know
with what we're doing
what have you said no to on I'm on a
yearly basis on a monthly basis you guys
have to be saying no we said no we don't
want a television show on this channel
no we don't want to sign this type of
development deal for this type of
television I mean most of things that
we've said notes who have all only been
because of the creative differences
don't mean that or the timing because
they'll be like hey everyone you guys
try to do it in a TV show if it gets
picked up you're gonna be shooting for X
amount of weeks every year and we're
like we can't sacrifice that much time
because we got to keep doing so much on
on YouTube and on our websites and stuff
right I mean you were there the night
when we were in Miami and we talked
about this early as amazed yeah well we
got the word that hey our television
show got picked up we got 10 episodes on
IFC and you know even in our minds it
was like is this a good thing and it
sounds like you guys made a decision
that you certainly had those
opportunities and if that was you
instead of us it sounds like you did say
no I'm not even I'm not even gonna pilot
something because we can't leave this
space right I mean you have if you if we
have the time and if we've if we have it
all planned out yeah we're totally open
to something like a TV show though you
have to do recurring if it's gonna be
successful but if it's something like a
movie which we're both interested in
doing at some point
it's you could block out 20 days and
you're like we just gotta get really
ahead beforehand so what what so what
are you gonna do is it a movie
have you written the script we might in
the future we're really interested in it
but you know the the overall plan for
Smosh isn't just about Ian and I so our
main focus isn't let's go do a movie
let's go be a huge Hollywood hotshots or
whatever let's let's grow the brand and
keep our comedy alive and as many
different forms as we can we have our
gaming channel we have a cartoon channel
we're trying to introduce new
personalities that totally get our humor
that we think our audience will like you
know like they love all the Smosh games
guys now and they love Mari so those
those have been some personalities that
we've introduced that I totally get it
so is so more of that getting to other
other Smosh properties yeah other people
that we really love that we know that
our audience will totally get yeah
because I'm like we can't we can't
create 50 shows ourselves but we can
create other shows that other people
make that our audience can enjoy just as
much as they enjoy watching our shows
and I think that's that's cool is there
is there anything is there anything
somebody coming along and saying here
boys here's here's 20 million dollars
each to go live on an island and and
just wake up and have a drink everyday
and and spend time with your your loved
ones is there anything at this point
that would stop you from continuing to
pursue this I would really like to do
that because I because you I I know how
hard you guys work yeah yeah I know
Allen can get kind of boring I mean what
just insert whatever let's just call it
an isthmus oh yeah what whatever it yeah
it's still attached to land in some way
but what is it that if anything that
would kind of say oh you know okay we
don't have to keep we don't have to keep
pushing so I guess if I ran for
president I really love making the
videos and I really love just the
reaction of the audience and like I said
we went back to call me I love when
people say they love what we made or
what we had a part in yeah
like Anthony and I have had this
conversation like a million times like
what the hell are we gonna do after this
yeah and because I mean we love the
whole process and we love you know just
making people laugh and having people
enjoy the content so I mean we want to
keep doing what we're doing and then
also you know expanding that so we don't
have to have the same sort of workload
to 1 or 40 I'm not gonna lie though
again it gets it gets tough and there's
there's times where I really do where I
would take that offer for a certain
amount of time but like I go on vacation
somewhere for a week and it's like the
most needed thing ever and after I'm
done I get back home I'm like alright
let's do this again yeah like I just
love it so much but you know I just feel
like I need I need breaks in there
right sure you guys can relate to this
yeah well guys thanks for coming it was
good to is good to get to know you and
now you got to sign this table you could
grasp each other's hand and do the we do
decide we draw the flying gas mask yes
we should
[Music]
that's our ear biscuit with Smosh tweet
at them and let them know you
appreciated the ear biscuit at smosh
ianh and at Smosh Anthony are there
personal Twitter hashtag air biscuit so
simple that's good I was smart
thoughtful yeah let them know that
you're glad they came on we appreciated
that and their friendship as well at the
20 million dollar question that you
asked that a 20 million dollar question
specifically the meaning the question
about 20 million dollars would you take
the money and run I'll put it back on
you since you asked them well but it
specifically involved an island oh so
your answer was any question oh if I
could take $20 I'd buy an island and
okay retinol obviously the the nature of
the question was if you could just be
totally set and and have all the money
that you need the security that you want
to have the relationships with loved
ones and have peace and quiet
would you take all that to leave the
career that you're doing that was a
question that I essentially presented to
them so what's your ask me boy here's
what here's what would happen I take the
money the twenty million dollars and
then I would immediately think man we
could do something pretty awesome with
this twenty million dollars we can come
up with the awesome idea to make to make
happen so I think the answer is a really
big robot
I wasn't thinking a robot but I was
thinking something a little more
creative thinking about how big the
robot would be between me pretty awesome
okay five million towards the awesome
robot fifteen million towards another
idea but then you're like nickel and
diamond I mean if I was well another
million he'll be like another six foot
taller I think then all of a sudden you
got a twenty million dollar 130 foot
robot and then what what was you dude is
he'd then make money I think he's
probably a movie star I don't know
he's a library star retro bike he's got
human flesh on him and stuff I think
it's gonna take more than 20 mil yeah
probably said I'll take 60 mil maybe 80
I mean freaking I mean that puts things
in perspective right there the stealth
bomber
like a billion dollars man yeah that's
what sucks about it you think you're
rich and then all of a sudden you you
you've built a fleshy foot of a robot
and you're like I'm out
it's like those houses we used to
encounter like back in Harnett County
that would be half built well that would
be a nice house if somebody completed it
I think the honest answer is is that I
don't think there's any amount of money
or any particular thing relaxation or
not that I would be like you know yeah I
don't want to keep I don't want to keep
creating I get tired of certain things
right doing the same thing over and over
again or whatever but I don't get hired
a job the job
yeah it's if we have a job a dream job I
think that what I would do with the
money I would give the correct answer
here and I don't say I would start an
endowment for other people to have the
freedom to follow in our footsteps
that's nice no strings attached very
nice of you and and advance the cause of
Internet tainment where the problem is
is you don't get the money unless you
take it and go to the island that's my
stipulation so or you can't build a
robot with it either so forget that oh
okay
your only requirement to get the 20 mil
from our endowment is to listen to all
ear biscuits and look you're already
doing that so you're well on your way
and we thank you I think you just made a
legal promise to lots of people about 20
million dollars just for listening to
every episode of your biscuit so as
links unofficial legal counsel I will
say here attracts that statement and we
really do want you to listen to every
air biscuit but you will not be
receiving any money for doing so thanks
for leaving a review on iTunes if you do
that you're back in the running for the
20 mil endowment okay you can officially
in the running for the non-existent 20
million dollar endowment yes and if you
use hashtag ear biscuits to let us know
give us feedback on the show across all
social media you're in the top ten for
the twenty million dollars okay I would
like to retract that statement there is
no top ten there's no endowment but
there is a 100-foot flesh cover robots
like that will come to your house and
present you with a check yep for ten
dollars and from a footnote all of the
is imaginary and including the robot of
flesh covering and the check and the
endowment and everything like I said
during the past five minutes all
imaginary non-existent in quote see you
on the island
[Music]
[Music]